the House Judiciary Committee is
expected to finally pass articles of
impeachment against President Trump in
just a few hours the votes will take
place here in the Ways and Means
Committee room it's the very same room
where they were supposed to finish up
yesterday but instead bitter partisan
arguments lasted from the middle of the
morning to late into the night before
Democrats finally post hone the votes
Nancy Cordes is outside that hearing
room for us Nancy good morning what's
going to happen today well they are
going to take two back-to-back votes
really and truly on abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress now those votes
were expected to take place as you
mentioned yesterday instead we watched
14 hours of debate play out and at the
end of the day only one amendment passed
changing the name in the resolution from
Donald J Trump - Donald John Trump
around 11:15 last night chairman Jerry
Nadler abruptly adjourned the hearing
infuriating Republicans who said it was
done so that the vote could play out on
TV you chose not to consult the ranking
member on a scheduled issue of this
magnitude so typical this is the this is
the kangaroo court that we're talking
about where stalin s.u stalin desk
Democrats say it's more transparent to
hold the vote during the day and not
close to midnight now if and when these
articles do pass today that will lead to
a full house vote to formally impeach
the president sometime next week
Wednesday right now is the target day
and from there the case heads to the
republican-controlled Senate for a trial
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell says he
expects that will begin in January as
for the president he is already
expressing his frustrations on Twitter
this morning after tweeting and
retweeting more than 120 times yesterday
Wow Nancy thank you chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett is with us
this morning major good morning good
morning everybody
as we heard Nancy say aiming for a full
House vote yep next Wednesday
how is the White House gonna outline its
defense the way it has throughout this
process here's a metaphor and vil hammer
dad nothing wrong bang read the
transcript bang process bad bang
democrats obsessed with impeachment bang
it's not subtle but polling data
suggests it's been more effective than
the White House thought it would be when
it started this process we'd likely to
see any defections from either side at
this stage so the key issue for House
Democrats - House Democrats voted
against launching the inquiry in the
first place no Republicans voted for it
every Republican I've talked to White
House and on Capitol Hill say there will
be no Republican defections they're
gonna stick with the president
completely as - we'll remember them for
that will house Democrats who voted for
the inquiry not vote for either one of
these two impeachment articles it is
possible I wouldn't say there's gonna be
a huge number of defections but any
number larger than two Republicans will
point to in the white house will point
to you and say see this case on full
public view on television hour after
hour didn't even persuade some House
Democrats so we are by my count about
two steps away from a potential trial -
there's a Judiciary Committee vote and
there's a full house vote at which point
it would go to the Senate yet where a
trial we heard next year next year
January the White House wants to have a
long trial but it sounds like the Senate
leaders want to have a short trial
what's going on here so this is a quasi
legal and entirely political process it
is constitutionally sanctioned but the
politics of it are real they're
coordinating the White House and course
of course as you would expect them to
and the White House wants to talk a very
big aggressive game about a trial that
is full of witnesses and Nancy Pelosi
and Adam Schiff and Hunter Biden and
maybe Joe Biden I think that is more
bluff than reality
I think if presented with the option mr.
president
we can have a summary of arguments and
we could dispatch with this in less than
two weeks and you can claim exoneration
we can move on the president will take
that deal and I think that is exactly
what Mitch McConnell and Senate
Republicans are outlining Donald Trump's
pre presidential history litigate until
the end to get what
what does he want to be exonerated or
not removed from office and have this
off you can get that faster if he goes
the no witness you talk long group you
talk to Democratic presidential
candidates and they say out on the
campaign trail nobody brings up
impeachment yes it's just it's not a
topic of discussion or at least not
initially write you is there any regret
among Democrats you think that they've
pushed this impeachment so I don't think
there's any regret I do really believe
that you should at this point because
impeachment is so large take them at
their word this body of evidence looks
to us so grave so concerning it must be
dealt with yeah and history will deal
with this not just in the present but in
the future that's their point of view as
I've told everyone with impeachment it
lasts forever it is not an act that is
hunt that leaves the Congress that does
it or the president that's accused of it
untouched and history will be the judge
maybe not immediately maybe not even by
an over over 20 20 full e but over time
we'll see if any voters punish members
of Congress for their votes they'll be
watching closely I'm sure major thank
you very much